se trata de uno de los mayores rescates
jamás realizados en sudáfrica los
cormoranes se criaron en estos corrales
los polluelos fueron encontrados
abandonados por sus padres a mediados de
enero unos 50 voluntarios se tornaría y
noche para salvar el mayor número
posible de aves una misión difícil para
una especie que no tolera el cautiverio
durante los primeros días las primeras
semanas vimos una alta tasa de
mortalidad esto se debe en gran medida
al estrés que ya sufren estas aves
debido a la deshidratación luego tuvimos
que lidiar con las infecciones
bacterianas los que sobrevivieron
aprendieron a nadar a volar ya comer los
cormoranes se alimentan principalmente
de anchoas y sardinas pero frente a
ciudad del cabo cada vez hay menos peces
pequeños el abandono de estas aves se
debe a que los adultos no tenían
alimentos esta es la teoría de estos
investigadores preocupados por las
consecuencias medioambientales de la
pesca
es muy difícil tener un enfoque
ecológico de la pesca porque siempre
prevalecen los intereses industriales y
me preocupa que no se tenga debidamente
en cuenta en el impacto en los
ecosistemas
porque no solo los cormoranes carecen de
peces pequeños la población de pingüinos
africanos ha disminuido en un 90% desde
la década de 1950 en parte porque ya no
pueden encontrar alimento en el fondo
marino de la península del cable lejos
de los arrastreros industriales algunos
pescadores son muy conscientes de su
impacto en el medio ambiente
ahora mismo estamos rastreando las hoy
reinando la para encontrar el lugar
exacto donde vamos a lanzar nuestras
líneas de pesca ahora online aguante en
sus cañas
la pesca del snow un pez de la familia
de las barracudas es la más tradicional
de la región pero para ganarse la vida
estos pescadores deben traer más de 100
veces al día
trabajamos cada vez más duro para
capturar cada vez menos peces eventos
esos otros barcos también intentan
ganarse la vida el snow el pez que
pescamos hoy en día bueno cuando yo era
pequeño había es no es que a lo largo de
la costa todo el año hoy hay sólo por
dos meses
estos pescadores afirman que capturan en
un año lo que algunos arrastreros
industriales a veces capturan en un día
acosan a los barcos extranjeros de
despoblar sus océanos
si yo diría que son los extranjeros
china se acercan bastante así que
mientras ellos pescan anchoas y sardinas
nosotros nos ponemos en su estela para
capturar los snow que son atraídos por
estos pececillos el problema es que sus
redes atrapan mucho
la pesca artesanal también produce menos
capturas accesorias que la pesca
industrial es un tiburón es mi error
con una captura incidental
no liberaremos
la ventaja de este tipo de pesca
soltamos todo lo que no queremos
no solo los peces pequeños son víctimas
de los grandes barcos los tiburones
blancos por ejemplo son cada vez más
escasos en ciudad del cabo para los
biólogos marinos es esencial educar a la
población y ser conscientes de la
diversidad de nuestros tiburones
apreciar su importancia en el ecosistema
es importante estos depredadores en la
cima de la cadena alimentaria desempeñan
un papel crucial en la estructura y el
funcionamiento de los ecosistemas
marinos pero los tiburones más pequeños
los que no son super depredadores
también juegan un papel esencial
tiburones peces camarones la gente debe
darse cuenta de que todos son
importantes y que el mar sigue siendo
una fuente primaria de alimento los
científicos también asesoran a las
autoridades trabajan con los ministerios
para evitar la sobrepesca y el
contrabando todo esto se toma muy en
serio en sudáfrica
hace apenas unos días se informó en las
noticias que el líder de un grupo de
cazadores furtivos que habíamos
perseguido fue condenado a un total de
244 años de prisión
habilidad en varios casos de hecho va a
pasar 18 años entre rejas
y se ha saltado la ley y ha sido
castigado
los pescadores locales tienen que
respetar las cuotas que se revisan
periódicamente los científicos trabajan
para proteger las especies en peligro de
extinción los cormoranes rescatados son
liberados gradualmente en la isla donde
nacieron
con los esfuerzos combinados de todos la
montaña de la mesa puede conservar una
de las biodiversidades más ricas del
mundo